hallo ihr lieben seid ihr auf der suche
nach dem perfekten sind reichen dann
seid ihr hier genau richtig okay das hat
sich eine dauerwerbesendung aber was
dieses rezept angeht da stehe ich sowas
von hinter und ich mache dass er die
jahren nicht anders deshalb zeige ich
euch jetzt die zutaten für richtig
leckere brötchen und zwar benötigen wir
mehr lauwarme milch 1 1 etwas
speisestärke außerdem trockene oder
frische hefe vor der zucker
vanillezucker eine prise salz zum
befüllen etwas rohrzucker sind und wer
mag noch ein paar mandeln oder andere
nüsse und wir benötigen noch reichlich
weiche butter und zuallererst bereiten
wir unseren süßem hefeteig zu dafür
nehme ich jetzt einfach das mehl es ist
ja schon in einer ausreichend großen
schüssel gebe da alle trockenen zutaten
hinein
das heißt einmal speisestärke dem
puderzucker vanillezucker und die prise
salz die hebt noch mal den süßen
geschmack und außerdem noch die
trockenhefe
und jetzt ganz kurz mit dem schneebesen
miteinander verrühren und jetzt gebe ich
in die mitte des mehls dann mache ich
jetzt erstmal eine kleine mulde gebe da
milch hinein besser ist wenn sie lauwarm
ist und arbeitet die hefe besser und
außerdem noch das ei und falls ihr jetzt
sagt ich möchte lieber frische hefe
verwenden dann geht ihr wie folgt vor
einfach die frische hilfe in der lava
milch auflösen mit dem puderzucker das
ganze zehn minuten stehen lassen und
dann mit zum teil geben aber mit
trockener hier funktioniert das gut und
die habe ich immer da
[Musik]
ich habe den teig jetzt noch ungefähr
fünf minuten lang auf der arbeitsfläche
geknetet natürlich könnt ihr eure
küchenmaschine nimmt aber heute habe ich
mir gedacht nee kein schnickschnack wir
machen alles mit den händen
jetzt habe ich das zu einer kugel
zusammen gerollt gibt es zurück in die
schüssel und jetzt entweder mit ein
bisschen mehl bestäuben oder back trends
bei hauptsache der teig klebt später
nicht an der schüssel und dann sehen wir
uns in circa einer stunde wieder nach
einer stunde hat sich der teig
verdoppelt und wir werden jetzt auf der
arbeitsfläche ausrollen so rechteckig
ungefähr 50 mal 40 zentimeter da müsste
jetzt nicht so perfekt und genau sein
und ihr braucht in der regel kein extra
mail zum ausfallenden der teig ist super
der kippt überhaupt nicht an der
arbeitsfläche
[Musik]
so fertig ich glaube wenn ich das
gewusst hätte dass wir in drei kommen ja
aber ich glaube wir hätten wir
croissants gemacht wenn es dreckig
geworden wäre so als nächstes werden das
ganze mit der weichen butter bestreichen
einfach mit einem pinsel oder was mir
ein bisschen einfacher fällt mit einer
winkel palette
dann gibt es ein bisschen einfacher den
teig habe ich jetzt schön mit der
weichen butter bestrichen als nächstes
muss die auflaufform ebenfalls mit
weicher butter bestrichen werden
da habe ich einfach meinen pinsel
genommen und das gebe ich es ganz kurz
zur seite
denn jetzt geht es ja um die füllung wir
gefühl dass jetzt mit dem leckeren
braunen zucker der später schön
karamellisiert und vermischung mit dem
zimt vorher
[Musik]
und im nächsten schritt wird unser zum
zocker auf dem teig verteilt und
anschließend gebe ich auch noch die man
ihn dazu
hierzu auch ein kleiner hinweis ihr
könnt natürlich auch zum beispiel
wahlliste nehmen oder rosinen oder das
ganze ganz weglassen dass es auch wieder
geschmackssache
[Musik]
und die mandeln sorgen später führen
richtig schön bis also wenn ihr das mögt
dann macht auf jeden fall mit rein
als nächstes haben wir zwei
möglichkeiten die erste möglichkeit ist
entweder alles auf rollen und dann in so
kleine scheiben schneiden ich persönlich
mag es eher weniger denn die optics ist
ja auch ganz wichtig und deswegen nehme
ich mir jetzt einfach meine meine pizza
roller und schneide das erst mal in
zwölf gleichmäßig lange strenge das
heißt ein strahlendes ungefähr 4 cm
breit und dann wollen wir das auf und
dann werdet ihr sehen warum ich das viel
hübscher finde
so und jetzt habe ich das ganze
aufgeteilt in zwölf werde dass es einmal
längs durchschneiden und jetzt einfach
richtig schön eng aufrollen
[Musik]
und hier ist unsere erste zentrale und
ich weiß nicht ob er mich verstehen
könnt aber ich finde das hat vielmehr
dimension haben so kannst du dich mein
herankommen dimensionen
sag mal ich finde das sieht viel
hübscher auswahl ist auch so ein
bisschen nach oben geht und nicht so
platt gedrückt ist und das gebe ich
jetzt in meiner auflaufformen
[Musik]
und im nächsten schritt müssen sie diese
nehmen wollten nochmal abgedeckt geben
lassen in einem warmen ort für
mindestens 45 minuten besser ist eine
stunde und dann wandern sie in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze für ca 25 minuten dann
kommt sie richtig schön gold braun raus
[Musik]
nach 25 minuten sind die goldbraune
szene sitzt fast fertig fast denn das
wichtigste fehlt noch unser leckeres
frosting und das besteht aus drei
zutaten und zwar einmal puderzucker
dann habe ich hier doppel rahmen
frischkäse und etwas vanille extrakte
könnte auch vanille zucker oder auch zum
pool übernehmen das sind wieder
geschmackssache man jetzt die zutaten
ganz einfach miteinander zu reden und
dann auch die cinemaxx geben
[Musik]
so ihr lieben das greenpeace frosting
ist jetzt auch drauf und ich mache das
frosting immer direkt nach dem
backvorgang drauf weil ich die auch
gerne noch warmen genießen und das
empfehle ich euch auch sehr ihr könnt
ihr am nächsten tag auch mit dem
vorstehen einfach in die mikrowelle
geben für eine minute auf höchster stufe
dann ist es auch wieder richtig schön
warm und natürlich gibt's auch kalt auch
kein problem
falls ihr mich jetzt fragt ob er das
ganze einfrieren könnt ist auch kein
thema dann würde ich es vorziehen nicht
drauf geben einfach einfrieren und wenn
das dann genießen möchte da gibt es
einfach am mikro welt und macht das
frosting drauf ich freue mich jetzt wenn
ihr den leckeren und vor allem richtig
weichen zum brechen nach macht das
rezept findet ihr hier unten in der
infobox könnt ihr mich gerne wieder auf
den fotos verlinken die mir über
instagram zukommen lässt und ich freue
mich wenn ihr meinen kann kostenlos
abonniert einen daumen nach oben gibt
und beim nächsten mal auch wieder
einschaltet tschüss
[Musik]